We usually think of Astronauts in only the
most heroic terms.
Brave women and men in peak physical and mental
shape who will risk it all to further humanity’s
reach into the great beyond.
But as the Japanese author Taro Gomi so eloquently
put it, everyone poops.
And NASA is still looking for the number one
way to dispose of number two.
When we first started taking baby steps into
space, NASA tried to get around the problem
by keeping astronauts from having to go entirely.
Weightlessness actually makes poop travel
through the body faster, so to counteract
this for short missions astronauts ate a low
fiber diet for three days before launch.
The early days of longer crewed missions had
the most crude solutions.
Apollo astronauts used what was essentially
a plastic bag taped to their butts.
And yes, the bags were clear,
I guess so the astronauts could see if they
had the right stuff.
It may shock you but dropping space trou and
pinching off a brown asteroid into a bag didn’t
always go smoothly.
Famously the Apollo 10 mission, the dress
rehearsal for the moon landing and the step
before the giant leap for mankind, had an
unexpected passenger along for the ride.
It happened six days into the mission.
Commander Tom Stafford was the first to notice
it: a turd floating around inside the capsule [laughs].
It happened 6 days into the mission.
Commander Tom Stafford was the first to notice
it: a turd floating around inside the capsule.
Between fits of laughter the three astronauts
on board all denied ownership of said turd
claiming they would have known if they had
pooped on the floor, or that their poop was
more sticky.
Regardless Stafford stepped up and grabbed
the space waste with a napkin, and that’s
why he was the commander.
To this day no one has owned up to it, but
the transcripts of the exchange are public
record.
My favorite part is they were at one time
marked “Confidential,” presumably to keep
the Russians from learning about our state
of the art butt bag technology.
The space shuttle had a more conventional
toilet, though it required training with an
underseat video camera to master.
Yes shuttle astronauts were toilet trained
twice in their lives.
Today astronauts on the International Space
Station have a vacuum powered toilet to catch
any floaters.
It even has a seatbelt, probably to keep them
in place in a microgravity environment, but
maybe in case they have a really intense session,
I don’t know.
But we haven’t stopped developing space
toilets, we’ve got our eyes and tushies
on the prize.
Yes, there is a prize for a better space loo.
Dr. Thatcher Cardon is a family doctor, a
flight surgeon, and a colonel in the US Air
Force.
In 2017 he added “Winner of the Space Poop
Challenge” to his many prestigious titles.
Dr. Thatcher developed a system that allowed
astronauts to go to the bathroom while still
in their suit, eliminating the need for diapers.
The system relies on an air lock at the astronauts
crotch.
When the astronaut takes off the cap, a self-closing
valve keeps air from escaping.
The astronaut can then insert a tube through
the valve that can be used to slide a number
of things inside the suit, like an inflatable
bedpan, a bidet, wet wipes, even fresh underwear.
This technology might not just help astronauts
avoid diaper rash, it could be essential if
their spacecraft is pierced by debris and
they have to spend days inside their suits.
For his sanitation innovation Dr. Cardon was
awarded $15,000, which is nothing to sniff
at.
As glamorous as space exploration is, it has
a funny way of reminding us that we are still
human, and still have to solve some very basic
human problems.
Rockets that get us to Mars are important,
but making sure the first person to set foot
on it doesn’t track poop on their boot is
important too.
If this video made you laugh, then I’m sorry
but you have to subscribe.
Those are the rules.
Poop’s not the only problematic waste.
In 1963 A Mercury capsule had several systems
go dark thanks to a leaky pee bag.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you next
time on Seeker.